or sometimes they move on to a different
coach because you know each chapter of
Life
offers a different need and and someone
else might be better at helping them
with it welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I'm with John newenberg who has
been a business coach since 2004. he has
helped over 300 small business owners
increase profit remove the stress and
Chaos from their businesses and get
their lives back before becoming a
business coach John was president of BC
Liquor Stores which currently does over
3 billion dollars in sales annually with
a head count of 4 000 people in 2019
McKay CEO forms awarded John with
Canada's CEO trusted advisor award in
the small business category
[Music]
John newenberg welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
today and I'm really excited to have you
here how are you I'm doing great thanks
for having me
uh John previously we're the president
of the BC Liquor Stores currently doing
over three billion dollars in sales
amulets a big big number with more than
4 000 people you've since 2004 been a
business coach helping more than 320
small business owners and so lots of
lots of experiences lots of stories I'm
sure so many different case studies and
and I'm really curious
um you know with the nature of this show
about leadership the different lessons
you've learned the different experiences
that you've had that helped shape your
own leadership style and what you found
to be most significant for you know
entrepreneurs Business Leaders and
leaders in general as they navigate
through these uh weird times and so John
again thank you for being here tell me a
little bit about your own look on your
own career the the connect the dots for
me in a high level of what you went
well it was uh that's funny you asked
Steve Jobs says that you can only
connect the dots going backwards right
yep that's where it's from yeah
and uh early days of being a
professional coach I had a bit of an
epiphany
uh which was that I've always been a
coach and and it was only in that moment
that I was able to connect the dots on
so to begin with I'm the eldest of eight
children so you can imagine that casts
you in a certain role pretty early in
life uh and I'm wired to be a teacher
and I knew that in high school but in
those days that meant wearing a Harris
Tweed coat and elbow patches so that
kind of bureaucratic style of uh
teaching wasn't for me
can you really exemplify how what does
it mean for a high schooler to know that
they are wired to be a teacher well what
how do in what situations did that come
about
you know I um I learned a very important
lesson from one of my brothers who um we
were both on the golf course and
um you know we're decent golfers but I'm
not anything like a professional or a
teaching level so I offered him a a bit
of a tip on something that I saw which
you know I'm hardwired to be a teacher
and his response to me which I've never
forgotten is thanks John but I don't
really want any help right now and uh so
that for me was
first kind of an answer to your question
on wired to be a teacher and wired to
offer those kind of tips and then
secondly the most important lesson I got
is I got to get permission if I want to
offer a tip so that was an important
teaching moment for me
tell me tell me more about that it feels
like it's a simple statement with a lot
of uh it's it's a it has a lot of
foundation to it well um you know a
coaching relationship is one where there
is permission given to inquire to lead a
process of discovery to help people
learn and to provide advice and some
perspective and stuff but in everyday
relationships people
um haven't given you that express
permission and as a result sometimes the
feedback you give is unwanted or
unwelcome I just had that 20 minutes ago
yeah
well there you go and so I learned from
that moment that just because I have
something to say doesn't mean that it's
right or welcome for me to offer but you
asked me about being wired to be a
teacher and uh and so I have to bite my
tongue sometimes because I I'm you know
have that instinct to do that in the
early 80s I learned something called the
Socratic method of leadership
so Socrates had the best way to help
somebody is to help them figure it out
for themselves and so if there's an
Essence to my leadership style that's
what it is that's to provide a space
where people can consider their options
you know offer some perspective and some
other ideas Etc but at the end of the
day my job is to help somebody get to a
place where they've arrived at an answer
that works for them and that they're
willing to act on and that's the essence
of coaching
so obviously the work that you do mainly
is in the situation where somebody
proactively
it grants you permission to coach them
and hopefully you're determined that
they're coachable and you embark on a
journey together so I have a lot of
questions on the sort of the personal
front as it but but I'm going to leave
that to an to a future episode because I
want I do want to focus on the scope of
this show
um and so
tell me about the the sort of the
coaching style that you have with people
what does that look like what have you
found to be the most enjoyable and
meaningful process for you and for them
well I worked through a framework called
the five steps of Freedom so
um
the purpose of a small business which
this is going to sound counter-intuitive
the purpose of a small business is to
give its owner the life they want
um if you're a bigger business and now
there are shareholders and other
stakeholders and more complexity this
you know this philosophy doesn't hold
but for the average small business owner
that their their business is to give
them their life and in many cases their
life isn't what they want it to be if
they could go out and Define here's what
I want for my life and often it's
because they're challenged around uh
time tumor money
uh and so they're saying things like
I've got too much to do not enough time
to do it I can't get everything done
probably you um it's I have a client
who's uh was had a hours commute uh to
and from work uh often he was working
till 10 o'clock at night and so he'd
rather than drive Holmen back but he
would stay overnight uh sleep on the
couch and one day his wife said so your
business is your mistress and if you
don't do something about it I will
and that's an extreme example but
um a common example of business owners
are so wrapped up and and feel like they
can't get away from their business or
don't have the the systems and structure
in place that allows them to to let the
business operate without their minute by
minute intervention so a lot of what I
help business owners do is around
leadership communication delegation
helping them understand
um what delegation truly is and that's
um the second part of what they often
want some help with is getting the right
team hiring is very difficult these days
getting the culture you want getting
people to work the level you need and
then the third thing is to do with money
so one aspect of that is having
proper financials reporting a dashboard
kpis on the other side of that is I need
more money I need better sales and
marketing
right I so that that personal piece
I mean I I would assume that in
traditional business coaching mindset
it's it's a lot about increasing profits
you know tackling challenges within the
workplace but you're mentioning that
that your work spans beyond that because
you have to take into account you know
the nature of the business the reason
for founding it and the really what what
this business aims to serve in the lives
of the people that are running it right
exactly
you know
um you're kind of hinting at something
that I'll uh share a little bit of a
secret that all business coaching is
personal coaching and disguise
so many business owners when they start
with business coaching and they think
it's because the business has issues and
it often does
but a large part of helping that owner
is developing skills around leadership
communication delegation and it's also
about helping them with
often with self-limiting beliefs or mind
issues around mindset that hold them
back from drawing themselves on the
business to the level that they can get
happiness from it
interesting I I miss I'm assuming that
uh it's an interesting mindset that the
business coaching is personal coaching
in Disguise yeah well another way that I
put it if the owner wants a better
business first the business needs a
better owner yeah right and so I imagine
that over with over 300 dead people you
you see that as a pattern emerging you
know
how how does one determine whether
they're they're right they it's time to
get a business coach a personal coach
um I'm not sure this is a directly in
the mindset of business owners or
startup entrepreneurs more relevant to
the show how how does one go about the
process of determining that
usually it's because they run up against
the ceiling they're bumping their heads
against
uh you know what they're capable of
getting out from the business and
they've tried everything they can think
of and none of those things have helped
solve their problem
um and um
um you know the
often the issue is that just because
you're good at the technical work of
your business doesn't mean you're good
at the business of your technical work
and so uh this is the the famous story
of Sarah loves baking cherry pies and
she likes it so much she opens a bakery
and then she discovers just because
she's good at bathing pies doesn't mean
she's good at running a bakery so
there's lots of business owners that
have you know got lots of training
they're you know seven years to get a
University degree and then they start to
practice a business and then discover
just because they're smart and law or
accounting or something like that
doesn't mean that they that they're
smart about running a business because
they never have the training to do that
and so uh that's at that point when they
recognize that that's when an owner
starts looking for help where can I get
some help with this is that is that the
right time in your opinion to to look
for help if you had to look at at the
the process from when somebody starts a
business or has an idea to start a
business to the point of crisis of I I
need help getting up from the the the
because it's been shattering underneath
me where in this pipeline would you
recommend the average person seek
assistance well before they get to the
crisis stage
um but it often takes that crisis for
the business owner to be willing to
consider it willing to look for
something different up until then
they're used to figuring it out they're
used to solving problems and uh and
they're used to saying you know I'll
work it out just enter you know by
Design stubborn
persistent uh and uh so it takes a bit
of a crisis off and sometimes in terms
of personal life sometimes it's because
you know they've got cash flow problems
or they can't make payroll or or an
issue like that but it it it it comes
because they've run out of their own
capacity to find answers
and so what for example can I do myself
as a entrepreneur
business owner and what can I do to
identify the right moments where I may
need to seek to seek assistance
throughout throughout my journey
well um
you know if you
anytime before the crisis occurs would
save you a lot of heartache
and so a lot of business owners feel
like it's not possible for them because
they can't afford it
um and um and what I'd say is it's it's
not a cost it pays in other words
business coaching will always produce a
return if it's done properly and you do
your prayer so it's actually an
investment or an investment major going
to get a return and so lots of owners
aren't you know they'll see their way
through that they just see it as an
expense and it's so it's again not until
it becomes a crisis that they're willing
to at least put it on the table
um but hey look at you can save yourself
a lot of Heartache if you get to a place
and say you know I'm really skilled at
whatever it is I do at my trade my craft
my profession but I've never had any
business training and I value training I
value education so maybe
um I I can save myself a lot of
Heartache it can get business training
before it becomes a crime cases have you
have you identified throughout your
coaching and personal experiences have
you identified patterns or common traits
or skill sets that differentiate the
incredible leaders from the good ones or
I mean I'm sure they that they're not
necessarily trivial things to for for me
to even conjure myself but I'm curious
if if you've seen you've seen both in
you know across all spectrums from
amazing leaders to to average leaders
what what really makes a difference here
dude there's a wonderful book called uh
crucial conversations and uh in it it
describes a crucial conversation anytime
emotions and Stakes are high
so the I think one of the Cornerstone
Cornerstone ways of thinking about
leadership is the leader the best
leaders are those that are most willing
and most capable of having a crucial
conversation and that's either with
staff with suppliers with customers
because a business owner will have
dozens
a week if not dozens a day of those
kinds of conversations and the better
the more willing you're on to embrace
that and the more capable more skills
you are at doing that the better results
you'll get as a leader so my definition
is
um those that are most willing and most
capable of having a crucial conversation
and then those are obviously two
different
uh two different things right capable
and willing
skills and willingness courage
and through coaching
does coaching satisfy one of them both
of them
or with a potential to satisfy I mean
well um there's a couple things I can do
about that first of all I can help
somebody say it
um right yeah well these are cush
conversations and secondly I can help
somebody uh develop the skills uh and
third to be more willing to do it
um so I see that quite a bit with
clients that are
um it's a difficult thing to do and lots
of them will avoid procrastinate
um and what I've learned is the harder
the longer you put it off the longer you
procrastinate the worse the problem
becomes so you're better off always
John's a curse and deal with it as soon
as you see it because that's the best
time to
um to to get a resolution
fantastic fantastic tell me a little bit
about your own um your own experience
what have you enjoyed most about you
know your own journey of coaching where
where do you where what which part of
are you most passionate about I'm
bringing this conversation back to you
now
yeah well uh again I'm hardwired to be a
teacher and so when I say that something
that's been part of a conversation part
of a coaching session uh gets
implemented executed and that it gets
results that's the most satisfying thing
for me and
um and so uh people then comment or
provide testimonials that so for me
coaching is helping people have better
lives and anytime I see evidence of that
that's the most rewarding thing that
makes coaching it was Mark Twain who
said if you're
um if you love what you do you never
have to work a day in your life and and
that for me is I'm fortunate to and feel
lucky that that's true
generally when people reach that you
know that phase where they would write
such a reflection testimony would or do
they generally continue with coaching or
do they then say okay I think I'm I'm
now ready for to to go and embark on
your challenges and revisit coaching as
I approach them
it's often towards the end of the
experience when they're reflecting you
know where they were and and where they
are today and um you know coaching is a
chapter in people's lives it isn't a
lifetime and often
um I've worked in some cases multiple
times with clients they we work together
for a period of time they take a break
from it they come back in a year or two
years or five years or sometimes they
move on to a different coach because you
know each chapter of life
um offers a different uh need and and
someone else might be better at helping
them with it John I really want to thank
you for your time and your energy and
effort I totally appreciate it I know
how busy you are and thank you for the
great insights uh lots of great notes
here on my own eh my own notebook for my
own leadership and my own Journey so
stay safe stay healthy and thank you
very very much it's my pleasure thanks
for having me